foreign
Jane is in Knoxville hi Jane how are you
better than I deserve what's up oh needs
so much up I need one of them swords to
slay a huge Dragon I might be your
toughest case you've ever had anyway my
husband is around he's been fixing to be
65 I'm around 59 and we have 10 kids I'm
homeschooling my last one she's 15.
anyway long story short I had to go to
work he got really sick and so he can't
work like he used to so I'm now working
I started working this past year and we
are definitely need help we have quite a
bit of debt and I don't know where to
start so I have a car that we made a
huge mistake and got a new vehicle and
we owe about 54 maybe 53 000 on it which
is I know crazy but we didn't really
have a good vehicle for me to go to work
in so I we did something stupid so long
story short how do we that was my first
question do we sell that to try to get
out of the stat but I finally realized
that we're old enough we need to wish we
had these things in plan but I've been
homeschool all my life so this is all
new to me what's the car worth
[Music]
um
probably 42 43. what's your household
income
85 yes you need to sell it
yes you shouldn't have bought it yes you
shouldn't have who's got the loan
uh Hyundai
okay
how bad your credit
it's good I have good credit because
that'll run over the credit union or
your local bank and get an unsecured
loan for fifteen thousand by three
thousand dollar car and cover the 12 000
hole we are in and sell it
okay could you say that again you got to
borrow the amount that you're in the
hole
in order to sell it plus three thousand
dollars to get a car
because you got no car right no he has
his truck for the farm but we don't have
a car get your little three thousand
dollar car to get around and you don't
you don't need 43 000 our car to go to
work Okay so
I'm at a 40 and um a small forty
thousand dollars on a tractor
bad I got really sick almost died so it
changed our lives two years ago
um you live on the farm
we do live on the farm that's a long
story but we can't sell it because it we
found out it's in a trust that his
parents had put in so we we take care of
it we have no money to take care of it
but what we make and so we can't sell it
so uh sell the tractor and Lease the
land
let somebody else Farm it your husband's
sick and you can't afford the tractor
and you're not making any money anyway
so the tractor leaves the land that
sounds great let somebody get another
farmer to lease it what's your husband
been growing on it
um
um I'm trying to think what all he does
uh corn soybeans
they've done a lot of different stuff
too I'm not even sure I mean if it's
pretty standard deal is other another
Farmer in the area Farms it and you get
a percentage of the crop as your lease
payment
that's a pretty standard arrangement I
assume that can go to you I don't know
you don't own it
no it's a terrible situation I don't
know if it goes to the trust or not
no it doesn't I mean if you make money
on the farm you don't have to give it to
the trust right no we don't because we
have to pay the taxes and all the stuff
for it it's just it's just in a trust I
mean all the land's tied up in a trust
who is the parent
I'm sorry what did you say that's okay
I'm uh I'm aghast
um yes so am I this is not a blessing so
this is his family farm
his grandpa had it yes his Grandpa's
grandpa had it yes okay and so they
don't they they put it into a trust so
that it doesn't get sold that's exactly
and then we didn't realize that we
actually paid money for the house when
we moved here but we did not know until
after they passed away that they
actually put the house in with the trust
so we don't even own the house
yeah
okay wow and so I assume upon your death
that the trust goes to your kids
they're cursed with this as well that's
exactly
yeah
yeah wow
I guess there's no way to do anything
about it I don't know
I don't either but I'm going to see an
attorney uh and try to figure out
because I don't my obligation to a toxic
situation is pretty low
um I mean what happens to this beautiful
plan if you all just move off
you quit paying the taxes that's my
question yeah the trust will get trust
will lose it if you don't pay the taxes
because you're getting no benefit from
this thing at all no we're not and
there's no penalty on them that's why we
are where we are who is the trustee
huh
you need to go see an attorney
hey do you reckon
you reckon that much no I go to an
estate planning attorney there in
Knoxville find ask around find out who
does good estate planning work because
this probably needs to be busted up I
hate to sell family land like this but
it has become a curse rather than a
blessing
and I love land and I love family
tradition and Legacy and I'm about as
the older I get the more emotional I get
about that kind of stuff but this has
not been a blessing to you and it's not
going to be a blessing to your kids
that's
because it's poorly structured and so
y'all need to figure out what the flip
so go yeah spend a little money on an
attorney let's get out of the car and
get out of the car deal and get out of
the tractor deal what other debt is
there
uh we have a personal loan for 30 that
we
that because you have so many payments
you can't breathe yeah that's right and
nothing really and nothing coming in
well once you get out of that car and
tractor you'll be able to throw
something at that personal loan and
knock that out yeah and then that'll be
it
right yeah just tear that down and tear
down whatever hole we were in on the car
and you may be in a hole on the tractor
as well but um maybe you can get a
farmer to take that tractor and buy it
as a part of leasing the deal if you
want to investigate that but also
investigate uh busting up the trust
which by the way will solve the whole
problem because now you're in control of
the asset you can sell off to you know
50 acres of this and all of a sudden
you've got some money and you're debt
free so um and keep a 450 of it I mean
you'd be just fine so Dave you get in a
you somebody passes away and you're part
of a trust you're a part of their will
you can't you can't just simply Decline
and say I don't want it
well you can fail to perform the things
they're asking to perform the weird
thing here is that he's the trustee the
trustees who has the control
um and so depending I'm not an attorney
but depending on how the trust is
written the trustee is supposed to
execute the terms of the trust but also
the TR if somebody's going to break it
up it's going to be the trustee and her
husband's a trustee yeah so if it was
some third party attorney or his uncle
or somebody was the trustee
then he you know you might not be able
to get anywhere with it but when you're
the trustee of your own trust I mean
that's
yeah so
um somebody was trying to do something
good and honorable and nice and keep
them keep it in the family but uh
instead they handcuffed the family yeah
and um have left them in a toxic
situation so that's what you've got to
be careful of of these things that go in
perpetuation you know a small example of
that that's not nearly as uh emotional
as you know we just went through the uh
if Dave dies this year meeting with my
family and with the leaders I have to do
this Monty Python meeting every year I'm
feeling much better it's just a flesh
wound and um we just talk about what
happens this year if Dave dies so one of
the things that one of the tenances
it's written down and that we go over in
that meeting every year is that uh
nothing that we do at Ramsey Solutions
is to be kept alive because it was
Dave's dream
okay that's good you're set free from
sacred cows that's good you should put a
bullet in all sacred cows and eat them
turn them into hamburger although you
would not he's gonna say do we have to
eat them Dave can we I want to eat them
but you I'll be dead and you're a vegan
turn it into a leather jacket how about
that there we go now we're talking get
some use out of that burger out of that
Beefalo but anyway yeah the the sacred
Tech cows and that's that's what these
things become especially generationally
like this yeah where you're like four
generations down and what you can't have
the foresight to know what what's going
to happen I wanted to turn my I turned
the kids loose and the Ramsey team loose
from doing something that I thought was
good 30 years ago or 20 years ago kill
it move on I want to turn loose
emotionally and legally yeah you go to
the next thing go go to what God has
given you to do that's good